mais pour philippe béchade rédacteur en
chef du site la bourse au quotidien tout
le monde sait que la rentrée sera
compliqué mais personne n'arrive à
anticiper sa gravité
moi ma grande interrogation c'est
comment vous comment les entreprises
vont gérer de nouvelles mesures de
confinement de distanciation social on
était revenu presque à la normale ou
avec on va dire une distance est ce une
distanciation que je pourrais bien
allégée et là on comprend que au 1er
septembre
on va revenir à deux là qu'on a lu
confinement à de la distanciation
sortent donc sa course pas trop trop de
problèmes dans le secteur tertiaire où
les gens vont pouvoir télétravailler
mais dans tout ce qui est justement pme
production tout ce qui est manufacturier
les enveloppes et tant qu'on ne vont pas
pouvoir reprendre le rythme normal ou
même vont être obligées de lever le pied
et de ralentir le rythme qu'on avait
retrouvé depuis la mi mai et là il ya
beaucoup d'entreprises qui à maman vont
se dire on ne peut pas maintenir au
chômage partiel des gens dont on peut
nous de nous demander de les maintenir à
un tiers par exemple ou à deux tiers des
effectifs pendant une période de 3 mois
6 mois
on ne sait pas ce qui est terrible c'est
l'incertitude c'est à dire contre on
voit bien que les choses vont se
compliquer au 1er septembre mais on ne
sait pas jusqu'où est il ya des
entreprises qui face à la baisse de
leurs possibilités de répondre à la
demande vont certainement aussi mettre
des plans de chômage partiel voire voire
des licenciements